president Trump's former campaign
chairman Paul Manafort is in federal
court for the start of his high-stakes
criminal trial this marks a new public
phase in Special Counsel Robert Muller's
14-month Russia investigation Manafort
faces bank fraud and tax evasion charges
tied to his lobbying work for a
russia-backed political party in Ukraine
if convicted he could serve life in
prison Paula Reed is outside the court
house in Alexandria Virginia with how
the Russia investigation looms over this
trial Paula good morning good morning
these stakes could not be higher for
President Trump or Special Counsel
robert muller as jury selection gets
underway here at federal court in
virginia now there is nothing in these
charges about Russian interference in
the campaign but this case is the first
public test for Special Counsel Robert
Muller he had been hoping that mana fort
would flip and share what he knows about
any Russian involvement in the campaign
but we spoke to Manta Ford's lawyer just
moments ago as he entered court here for
the first day of this trial he told me
there is no chance that manda fort will
strike a last-minute deal to avoid trial
now this case will involve 35 witnesses
and more than 500 pieces of evidence in
an attempt to prove that mana fort
earned tens of millions of dollars from
his work with Ukrainian officials they
also allege that he hid a significant
percentage of that money from the IRS
and spend it on expensive homes cars and
even clothes as a way to launder that
money now one of the witnesses expected
to testify is former Deputy Trump
campaign Chairman Richard Gates who is
mana forts one-time business partner now
sources tell me that mana port is
banking on a presidential pardon if he
is convicted during this trial Paula
thank you